previously on TVs hit so there's this
rave tide okay at that club let's bolt
this place has everything
best sets key fobs kale chips okay how
many guys didn't watch the studio 60
since high school seems like as good a
time as any to roll commercials actually
if the show first aired in 1986 and this
is 2006 then this would be the 21st
season show doesn't know how to count
the one so it's SNL then right but it
can't actually be SNL so they changed
the day of the week and other details
but that makes the suspension of
disbelief really difficult we know the
real thing that it's based on and we
know that this is the fake thing clearly
imitating the real thing doesn't matter
how hard you work in the dialogue that's
a difficult mental hurdle to clear be
simpler times of 2006 when one could
call a show on one of the network's to
smash it sweet with the three 6 mafia
here at least that would be one Oscar
winner in the cast tell my secretary I
want the chairman of NBS NBS really
you're telling me in a world where ABC
and NBC exists there would be a
competing Network called NBS I'm calling
shenanigans what do you want me to say
to the 50 million people who are gonna
go out of their minds as soon as it airs
first of all you can tell them that we
average nine million households so
that's at least 41 million or full of
crap do your John will be great TV since
and the second you can tell them that
living where this free speech means
sometimes you get offended actually I'm
gonna have to side with Sirius man over
taxi here technically this is a private
corporate entity so free speech isn't
really even the consideration personal
vision man is not funny it's never been
funny then why did it even make it past
the writers room someone couldn't see
how unfunny it was even though it was
right in front of their face wait tell
the writers room they're gonna have to
stretch it another 25 seconds and I'm
sure they're making it longer was the
missing ingredient making it funny for
some strange reason I'm taking that
comment personally which is in how we do
in almost eerie Elaine on Wisteria Lane
we'd invite the suspect over to our book
club you know actually I was told these
were gonna change are these the newest
cards sorry Felicity but apparently not
only weren't they rewritten but every
card is the same since he just changed
the cards and yet from the front it's
the same sentence you just read
decisions
are we going with the [ __ ] dress or
the very [ __ ] dress they just said 90
seconds until the air I get these live
shows or insanity and a bowl of more
insanity
but they would at least have Felicity
Huffman in the proper [ __ ] dress at
this point right I need the very [ __ ]
dress and somebody else to wear it are
we taking suggestions asking for a
friend
my fellow Americans I'm here to speak to
you tonight about a very serious subject
my legacy is that supposed to be W and
Cheney I mean I've seen some rough SNL
and maybe I'm just still fresh from
bales of Ice Capades but there is no
possible way and impression this bland
would make it to air perhaps if you're
gonna do a show on sketch comedy you
should hire some sketch comedians well
there's always been a struggle between
art and commerce and now I'm telling you
all right it's getting his ass kicked if
this shows opening that worked any
harder I think it was attending a
multi-level marketing convention people
have well it's official Aaron Sorkin is
a Precog I knew there was something up
with that guy pretty sure it'd be more
entertaining right now if it was Michael
the river the country also reading four
years of NBC where she saw two at the
Jay Leno Swank David Letterman on a
regular basis I mean we all have our
kinks but I do not remember that show at
all that's gonna happen on my first day
right character says nothing bad is
going to happen on my first day and
everyone else's phones go crazy with the
news of whatever bad indeed happened in
unison cliche sure it's possible that
even though he works in TV that he
wouldn't know the different tape sizes
but would he really try to insert the
whole thing long ways he's still bark at
least by the VCR dinner first the world
news but look jordan mcdeere gives makes
it appear she knows that this was the
sketch that replaced the better one and
she would have no way to know that or
know if the original sketch was worth
cutting or not less hadn't even gotten
the chance to tell her what the original
sketch was about in a paddy Chayefsky is
classic film network this is followed by
four other newscasts that reference
network Sorkin's going all out on
admitting how similar this is but once
again for those in the back admitting
things does not absolve things is there
something funny about this Jordan god
jack there's like seven things funny
about this I really wish I could play
you the five minutes of absolute gold
that's about to pour forth in this
meeting it's funny meaningful clever and
Aaron Sorkin is a gift from the writing
gods and I'm taking ten sins off and I'm
doing it while walking down a hallway I
don't know who the Booker's are even
gonna get it we're gonna be on our side
just to know
from the future I'll bet my measles
vaccination that new shows can find
someone to argue just about any sort of
nonsense we're gonna hire two people who
hate your guts and we're gonna do it you
know amanda peet it's absolutely
shredding through this Sorkin dialogue
and stealing the show I'm not saying she
hasn't had a career but the fact that
she hasn't had the career she deserved
is definitely a sin Karen here got
invited to the Friday night wrap party I
thought it might be a fun thing to do
after for studio 60 I would say a
convenient invite to the wrap party so
Jordan can get the chance to speak to
them as convenient but then I would be
undermining the absolute insanity of the
pace of the show maybe if the show let
itself breathe a little people would
have been more interested in sticking
around and she had mapped yes she
certainly did but that's not why we
broke up great
skip yeah yeah go up on the stage man
why you just want really yeah that's
great fine maybe he didn't realize they
were handing out his award okay I guess
it's possible he would be aloof enough
to not hear his actual name announced
but you're telling me the spotlight goes
on his partner hugs him and he still
doesn't know amigos Musketeers why mice
I'm not an expert on Christian people
Daphne was also my screen name on
christianmingle.com my throwback reggae
crunk infusion band at middle school
what I said to my wife after our first
viewing of gladiator or deep the episode
of scooby-doo mystery Inc I pitched in
2013 to the Cartoon Network and was told
very kindly to never put pen to paper
again if I wanted to keep my dignity I
gotta ask you something if it wasn't the
Star Spangled no no I would give all the
Kingston's I've ever given any show back
right now if Simon Helberg were to say
next
was it the Big Bang Theory hey guys yep
you're being called back to the studio
who everybody then why didn't you just
say everybody's being called back into
the studio you pronoun game playing
drama inducing excuse for human plot
device ready
wait they actually got everyone in here
and in place on the same night I'm not
saying the geographical logistics are
impossible I'm saying the business
logistics are do you know how many
executives boards agents managers and
lawyers dear God the lawyers that a
decision like this would have to go
through some horny psycho religious cult
tonight
yeah it's a wild wild country Amanda a
wild wild country indeed and Cooper
doesn't look like anything that's
canuckistan
ironically I'm the one who's high as a
paper kite right now but legitimately
stop talking now yeah you bet so excited
for six or seven seasons of Matthew
Perry killing it in this role
congratulations on uwj Writers Guild
Award
or do you watch them on your LCD display
after ordering something from your DC
Comics with the UPC code or did you go
to the ATM machine and use your PIN
number instead you want me to save all
this in a PDF form after you because if
you pointed a camera at two people
masturbating and be among the least
embarrassing things on the National
Broadcasting System I think that show
happened it was a remake of The Odd
Couple did he just take those steps two
at a time after having back surgery four
days ago I get that he's on painkillers
but an ounce of prevention man that you
can get another director you can get
someone good actually he could do that
and still run the show I'm not sure how
anyone thinks letting a script that's
already in development sit on its ass
for two years is the best decision
you're paying beavis and half-way 30,000
an episode hey we'll come up with the
outdated and forced nicknames around
here pocket full of mr. sunshine
goodness what's with the exuberant
applause here this group of people is
nervous for their jobs confused about
what's coming on and likely dead tired
since this is still somehow the same
night as they already did a full show
I'm guessing excited applause energy is
the furthest thing from their minds do
you like it yeah cuz we live here not
only for 22 episodes again according to
Jim managed 172 this is why we can't
have good things people
but we talking about practice man what
are we talking about practice capital
surrounded by pedophiles criminals and
drug addicts and that's just the House
of Representatives and that's
Schrodinger's paradox right is the cat
dead or is the cat not dead I'm not sure
nobody's perfect take this anymore I am
nobody's master got it I don't want you
here and I don't want you here Janice
was my safety net okay and now I have to
get a snake uh-huh why is that if I'm
gonna be an old lonely man I'm gonna
need a think you know a hook like that
guy in the subway who eats his own face
I know what you're thinking what the
heck is this handsome devil doing back
in the Oval Office well the truth is
this is just a set I had it built in my
basement in Texas so I could pretend to
still be president sometimes